[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantly kissing and this is the
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our guest today is the author of a left
for itself
david swift welcome to trigonometry hi
lads thanks for having me on
it's an absolute pleasure listen it's a
fantastic book uh thank you so
much for sending it to us we really
enjoyed reading it before we get into it
just tell everybody
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey that brings
you
sitting here with a massive backdrop of
books behind you so giving you lots of
authority
there we we've just got a blank canvas
behind us which
is a accurate reflection of the state of
our minds
uh yeah so i'm i suppose i did a phd a
few years ago
in history my old background
academically has been history
and yeah like a lot of people a lot of
young struggling academics
uh i'm on the sort of job market and
it's not looking great exactly
you know there's a real um surplus of
people with phds and not enough jobs to
go around
so my sort of second uh interest if you
like was thinking could i be a
sort of more popular writer you know who
wrote sort of academic
scholarly books but with a more sort of
popular focus or popular audience anyway
and yeah you know i'm from liverpool
originally um
don't necessarily sound like it that
much nowadays actually but there we are
and you know it somehow struck me a lot
when i was growing up
is this sort of the disconnect between
say the the left-wing politics of many
people in liverpool many working-class
people in liverpool
and say the left-wing politics of say
the contemporary labour party right so
when i went to university for example
everyone was very left-wing there
but usually in quite a different way
from the sort of people that i grew up
around
so that's sort of thing really that
sparked my interest in the um
the sort of the difference between the
the modern left as it is in britain and
america and western democracies
and the sort of people at the modern
left is actually fighting for or at
least
says that it's fighting for and when you
say the modern left
let's just clarify that because when
people use the word left invariably it
means
a million different things just as when
people use the term
the right yeah yeah well i'm using it in
quite an open sense right so
for for me left is anyone really sort of
including tony blair
right up into way past jeremy corbyn to
sort of people who think jeremy coleman
was a blair right sellout
uh who exactly so i don't just mean
liberals by the way right
you know and sort of sense of being you
know a sort of um i don't know a small
state personal freedom type person
nick clegg david laws you know orange
book liberal i don't really mean
liberals
i mean sort of socialist left economic
left and again i
include or i assume that when we're
talking about socialist left i mean
people who are also left-wing on say
race and gender and lgbt and all that
stuff
and what has been the chart the
evolution for us david over
you know particularly the second half of
the 20th century
in in britain and the united states in
terms of the transformation of the left
because i would put it to you
based on our conversations with past
guests people like paul
embry william clooster and others on the
left
that uh or what you might call that
afternoon if william closes on left but
anyway my point is
uh the sort of people that used to vote
for the labour party actually france is
probably a good example of this as well
um
don't seem to be the sort of people that
are driving those parties
uh that are choosing their candidates
that are forming the the bulk of their
support at the moment so
the word has stayed the same but the
meaning is seems to have changed quite
dramatically
uh so talk to us about the evolution
because there's a little
interesting tidbit in your book about
how actually women used to
to overwhelmingly vote conservative
something that now would be
uh difficult to imagine yeah
well i suppose there's a there's a few
different things going on right so
one of these processes uh i mean maybe
i'm different to paul embry in this
regard but one of these processes
actually thinks a good thing right
so the left or the labour party both in
the uk and also actually in the u.s
since like the new deal
uh roosevelt era has shifted from being
about
a certain kind of white working-class
man right and not just any working-class
person but somebody works in heavy
industry
somebody who's in the trade union right
that's what the left used to be
70 years ago it didn't have much to say
about women it didn't have much to say
about
uh black people in the us or immigrants
in the uk or in fact actually different
kinds of working-class men who weren't
in unions or did other kinds of jobs
like i don't know taxi drivers or being
self-employed or whatever
um and so actually i think that this
evolution now where the left is
genuinely paying attention to all of
these other very important things which
i think are important like race and
gender and so on
is actually a good thing however at the
same time there's been a
a sort of con committing process whereby
firstly
um the the sort of people as you say who
are
uh behind say they're not people who get
nominated to stand for elections behind
people who make decisions at the
leadership of the left
the public face on politics and uh talk
shows and so on
that has changed very much and that has
actually gone to people who are
you know rarely unrepresentative of of
of anyone of themselves right it's not
necessarily that you know
your average uh black or american
britain uh you know
is on the talk shows or right in the
leader columns or even wielding power at
the top of the labour party
so it's actually given rise to a very
specific um
kind of people who really don't
represent anyone and this is almost
where the title of the book comes from
are left for itself
like they're there for themselves and
their own specific group of people
and i think the problem here is that the
the sort of site of radicalization
if you like yeah which is it's no longer
the
the shop flow of a factory it's no
longer
um necessarily people who are being
overly discriminated against themselves
it's actually people who are acting out
of altruism and sympathy with other
people right the site of
radicalization now is the university
campus and
in a way it's fine you know i've got
nothing against altruism i've got
nothing against people
uh selflessly trying to act to help uh
people less fortunate than themselves
that's all right
but the problem is when the sort of you
know the majority of
the left the majority of left-wing
activists the majority have left twitter
the hellhole that is left twitter
when the majority of these people are
not trans people or black
people or white working class people
when the majority of them
are you know fairly well to do middle
class white people
then i think this is where the problem
comes in right because there's a real
disconnect between the actual foot
soldiers and activists on the one hand
and the sort of people they claim to be
fighting for on the other
and do you think that actually and maybe
this is me and my own prejudice coming
to the full but don't you feel that when
you know somebody who is comes from a
very well-off privately educated
background you know
tend to be white and upper middle class
and they start to say that they speak
for minorities
isn't this quite patronizing to be
brutally honest
oh yeah i mean 100 when someone said
that they speak for minorities etcetera
and you know
um it's almost like that the taking
other people's struggle to
to make themselves seem more interesting
or even to empower themselves really you
know
to get to give themselves a i don't know
media coverage to get themselves
kudos or whatever even to get themselves
tweet you know retweets and likes
when someone's doing it in that sense
yeah i think that's wrong in any sense
however
if somebody wants to you know be an ally
as the phrases you know
be a foot soldier in a movement for
other people i don't think that that's
necessarily wrong like i mean if you
look at
black lives matter in the us
irrespective of what you think of black
lives matter in the us
at least it's led by black people right
so i think
if white people want to help black lives
matter in the us then
you know all power to them right i mean
you might disagree with the objectives
or whatever but i don't think that is
necessarily patronizing
i think it is patronizing if white
people want to yeah as you say sort of
like speak
for black people you know what i mean
and sort of like act as their sort of
representatives and like they're
the warriors for them rather than rather
than taking a back seat
and being foot soldiers uh you know to
their greater cause david and how has
this happened because this process of
transformation which has led
in your assessment to a group of people
who only represent themselves being
the public voice of the left
increasingly so
people like owen jones ash sarkar aaron
pastani
etc in this country certainly uh i mean
i think cohen jones probably arguably
does represent a
a a sentiment of people on the left but
you know their soccers and aaron bustan
is people like that
in particular if they represent no one
how
how have they come to the position that
they're in
i mean it's not so much that they
represent no one it's they definitely
represent
a group of people uh i would say it's
quite a specific group of people though
and not the people that they perhaps
think
they're speaking or they think that
they're representing
i mean i think what's happened here is
you know there's all sorts of forces
going on on the one hand you've got the
decline of
uh you know traditional industries the
decline of trade unionism particularly
private sector trade unions and
you know that's one thing by itself at
the other hand you have this massive
political
proliferation excuse me of university
education
and also unfortunately at the same time
a decline in
uh the prestige of of the university
degree and also in the decline of
university quality jobs right you have
this
surplus as i was saying before but you
know there's so many phds not enough
academic
uh not enough academic positions and at
the same time you have so many people
with bas with mas
who aren't able to get the sort of job
commensurate with that kind of degree
the sort of job they thought they would
get
so they're a bit sort of stuck really
and but they all have internet access
and they all have social media accounts
and this is where you get this uh
this particular kind of left coming from
i think
and dave they seem to me that they wield
an almost
disproportionate power when you look at
the you know the people who agree with
them and who they represent
how has this been allowed to happen
well i mean it's it's interesting right
so there's this quota
used in the book by the sociologist
manuel castell so manuel castell said
when people can't control the world
around them they shrink
the world to to the size of their world
to something they can control
or timon the mere cat from the lion king
put it more the same thing
when he said when the world turns it's
back on you you turn your back on the
world right
and this is what's happened with a
certain section of the left because
they're actually completely shut out of
power aren't they you know i mean even
the mainstream
sort of new labor labour party hasn't
won an election
in this country in 10 years and
obviously many of the people i'm talking
about in the book
very much reject new labor again in the
u.s
um you know bernie sanders wins sorry
business excuse me if joe biden wins in
november okay great for the the
democrats again this is very sort of
mainstream
democrat and you know the still shut out
and many lower levels of power in the
senate
in you know state governorships state
congresses etc etc
um in terms of the board in you know in
terms of actual real economic change
right so you could say
uh you know the world capitalism and the
boardrooms of major companies uh
evolving on certain issues
but not really you know it's stylistic
aesthetic things that they're saying
they're not going to give away all their
wealth you know to the poor or anything
like that right
so in many ways it's uh
it's because i think on the one hand the
left
however you want to constitute it right
the broader left or quite a narrow left
because it has so little power in real
life it has so little political power
has so little economic power that on the
very in the very few spheres in which it
does
have influence such as social media such
as academia
it then uh tries to you know exercise
complete power right because that's the
one
that's the one thing it can do you know
i don't know if you're a football fan
but i remember years and years ago when
um pep guardiola and josie mourinho were
at barcelona and
real madrid respectively and uh pep
guardiola going on a
pep guardiol going on a rant in a press
conference saying you know
in this room he's the [ __ ] chief you
know this is his this is where he's the
master actually not in the football
field but in the press room
and i think it's a similar thing
happening with the left in a way you
know
it's because they don't have any real
power that they try to uh
sort of monopolize power in these very
specific spheres of social media in the
media
but i'll see your question as to how
that happened i think a problem is
that so many people are um
they they are really in fear of being
out flanked to their left
right because so many people and in a
country like the uk where
i think like almost 90 percent of the uk
is white right
so likewise the left academia
uh media and so on are overwhelmingly
white people overwhelmingly middle class
people
and so we're in you know we're not black
we're not trans we're not palestinian
and we'll speak for yourself mike
exactly
if you listen to our fans francis has
got some potential lesbianism going on
just about by his appearance
good stuff
[Laughter]
so diplomatic just skip over that that
problematic joke
and move on to something else fantastic
yeah um yeah so
i mean you may need this in a certain
way to entitle you to speak on certain
issues
yeah i have to say listen i am a lesbian
and soon enough you may be able to self
define as a lesbian and unfortunately
people might have to just
exactly go along with it so it's because
of this right it's because
so many of us we don't have the
almost credibility that actually being
black or asian or trans or palestinian
or being gay or being dead poor
would grant us so we're terrified or
someone left of being outflanked to the
left so we don't feel as though we can
stand up to these people
we don't feel as though we can say to
you know the sarcastanis or joneses
you're talking shite actually you know
you don't speak for anyone
because we don't necessarily feel that
we have the sort of demographic
credibility to say that
do you think there's a a kind of
morality gap there because
you know as i think many people have
articulated in the past
the the rights view of the left is that
the left are stupid and naive
and the left's view of the right is that
the right is evil
and so there is this kind of accepted
dogma i suppose that uh if you want to
become more moral you move to the left
if you want to become more pragmatic you
move to the right and therefore
to be outflanked to your left is to to
to kind of concede that you are
a less moral person and we've all kind
of bought into this
is that part of it i think there's
something to that yeah i think
definitely
uh and this is a more true on some uh
some issues than others for example
like um immigration which i'm not sure
will come up later but
um you know i would be much more
comfortable
i'd say an academic conference saying
that i wanted to abolish the nhs
and basically abolish income tax as well
right because whilst virtually everyone
in the audience or everyone there would
disagree with me
they would at least think that was a
legitimate political position
for a right-winger to put across i mean
i don't want to do these things by the
way but there we are
um but i wouldn't feel comfortable
saying i think we should like have no
immigration right which again i
definitely don't think by the way
that's not the way we're going to clip
it though i just want to make it clear
to you now
that's going to be the headline that's
going to be the title mate
david swift no immigration no nhs
no nhs no immigration no income tax
a perfect world according to david swift
that's it
so but this is it right so you know it's
unlike say
taxation or or health and welfare
spending
um immigration restrictions is not even
seen as a legitimate issue
for many people on the left uh and so
yeah i think there's a certain thing to
that about about morality and about how
it may be perceived actually as being
immoral to have certain opinions
rather than just political opinions that
you can agree or disagree
with and people are entitled to have
them even if you don't agree with them
having said that at the same time you
know it's so easy for
the right to just to ape these opinions
without actually following it through by
doing anything and get away with it you
know you look at the way
uh mainstream tory mps now talk about
all sorts of issues from
i don't know gay marriage to the
environment to even black lives matter
to immigration to crime and punishment
it's very easy for them actually to to
adopt
uh such many of the language of the left
on these issues without doing a damn
thing about it i mean you do have
a certain with boris johnson's cabinet
because he has to sort of you know he
doesn't have many people to choose from
so he has that to give birth to the
likes of pretty battelle and jacob
smog who do actually go against this and
do actually say things that
most uh career-minded tory mps wouldn't
say
necessarily but i think this is a thing
as well actually that the right can just
and this is a problem with the state of
the left that it's just so easy for the
right to adopt this language and
say the right thing and use the right
buzzwords and not do a damn thing to
actually help anyone
uh and so this is the problem when it
becomes more about morality than actual
change it's an interesting point that
you're making because
if you look at you know pretty patel
considered to be very hard line uh by
people
uh treated as almost like some kind of
you know evil witch by many
and you know considered to have a very
strong position in immigration but
actually
she you talk about being outflanked to
the left she's being outflanked to the
right
at this moment in time because you have
the illegal crossings
uh people coming into this country and
you know nigel farage is going why is
pretty patel putting these people up in
hotels and allowing this to happen
so it's almost like he's been he's
calling the bluff that
the the conservatives have have been
putting up
by parroting some of of what you might
call
more left-wing positions yeah well i
think there's you know the old marxist
idea of the base and the superstructure
right that you have like a sort of
uh objective material base
which has this uh political cultural
superstructure attached to it
i think in in many in politics nowadays
a similar thing is going on
in that you have the actual reality
right you have real life
uh you have people's you have public
opinion on say
the death penalty or immigration and
then at the same time you have
uh sort of what is uh permissible to say
you know the mainstream of politics the
mainstream policy
and the connection between the two is
very interesting and often very tenuous
right so
you know the death penalty was abolished
in the uk well 1967 i think or 65
possibly
and yet for the next sort of 50 plus
years the vast majority of public or at
least the slender majority of public
opinion
wanted to have the death penalty wants
to have capital punishment but it didn't
matter right because
there was no connection between that
sort of material desire
for capital punishment and what was
going to actually happen in politics
and again with immigration you know for
and for nearly
all of the past 70 years i mean as long
as there's been records as far as i'm
aware
there's been a disconnect between public
opinion on immigration
and what the politicians were willing to
even consider
um what you would would even discuss in
polite society
so and i think the exact same thing's
happening here right so
yes there are these uh illegal crossings
going on people landing in britain
illegally not going through the you know
legal immigration channels
and yes nigel farage and many people you
know much worse than nigel farage
are going to make hay out of this to a
certain extent but who cares it's not
going to make any difference
that's the sort of reality in the base
but actually there's this sort of
political super structure on top
which is decided that um it's just
it's not really a priority it's not
enough of a priority to actually make
the the you know the mainstream
politicians in the tory party
change their opinion or do anything
about it right and and and this is the
thing i think
i mean people say this about you know
before the brexit referendum and then
actually when the brexit referendum
happened it suddenly gave that
opportunity right for this sort of
frustrational movement on the on the
base to actually affect the political
superstructure
but i'm not sure if anything like that's
going to happen again
especially with first past the post you
know if we lived in a different system
with pr
you can imagine farage or a tommy
robinson figure or whoever
actually really feeding on this like the
afd in germany
really feeding on this and and winning
seats and stuff
but with first past the post they can't
see that happen and dave
we've been talking now about the left
and is it especially
that type of the left they're so
interested
in being moral they're so interested in
being right that really they don't seem
particularly interested in winning
elections is that fair
yeah i think i mean they would say oh we
are actually it's just you know
uh either we know the way we want to win
it you don't think it's what's going to
win but
we will we will win to follow this
advice or yes we want to win but not at
any cost right
and i think this is the problem because
you know it's not a binary right you
don't need
fraser that i saw a lot in january and
and you know when after corbyn was going
away and kia stammer looked like he was
storming to victory
in the labour leadership election the
phrase they often saw was throwing x
under the bus right throwing
palestinians under the bus
throwing trans people under the bus
whatever you know
you don't have to do that like you don't
have to actually
compromise on your values to win
elections you just need to be a bit
savvy about it i mean look at the tories
you know
the tories don't go the tories don't
literally say
listen you know we don't really believe
in the nhs and actually we're gonna you
know underfunded or whatever and in fact
you know they might not
they say oh we love the nhs oh you can
trust us with the nhs
you know they don't go and make jacob
reese mold leader the way labour made
jeremy corbyn leader
you know they make sure during election
time that jacoby smog was nowhere to be
seen
you know see this is the thing right you
don't act i'm not saying you need to
deceive the electorate although
arguably that's what the tory party does
but labour doesn't have to say
we're gonna do all these radical things
uh on say i don't know trans rights
we're gonna have a much more critical
position of israel you know
you don't actually have to go out and
and make your whole campaign about that
right
you can actually campaign on issues that
people care about
on issues where labour's position is
quite popular like on the nhs for
example
or on say taxation policy or nationalism
well economics i mean labor
labor's economic policies were
incredibly popular
it's almost a tremendous achievement
that they managed to lose the last
election while offering a manifesto that
was incredibly popular with people
this i mean this is the difficulty yeah
and i think one of the
i mean obviously there's brexit and all
that and this is having corbin as your
leader when
somebody is so unpopular uh and you have
this guy as the figurehead
so there's that but the problem is also
the tories can just pick and choose
better that you know the tories shifted
to the left
uh you know boris johnson said he's
going to build all these new hospitals
he's going to spend so much money and
then actually there's not enough
difference between them economically but
the tories have much more popular
cultural policies
or at least you know labour are shooting
themselves in the foot with some of
these policies which turn people up
so i don't necessarily think there's
this like binary or dichotomy between on
the one hand
sticking true to your values and your
moral positions and winning elections
you can actually do them both
you just have to be savvy about it and
the fact that so many of these hobbyist
left
people as i call them are just unwilling
to do that like
they're not even willing to just keep
quiet for a few months
win power and then change things shows
you that
for them it does seem to be about like
the the identity itself
like that actually for them just keeping
quiet about trans rights and palestinian
rights for six months to win elections
and then do lots of radical stuff on
trans and penn
they think oh no that would defy the
whole point the hope
is to identify ourselves with these
issues so that does make me think that
they're not interested in um
in winning elections uh dave i think
you'd have to confiscate their
smartphones if you were gonna do that to
be brutally honest with you yeah
it's the whole point is you know in the
same way that you know people who are
really into drum and bass or people who
are really into classical music
or you know whatever or people who are
massive liverpool fans or arsenal fans
they're not gonna just you know stop
supporting their team or or their hobby
just because it's it's impractical for
them or just because the team's suddenly
gone a bit crap
you know that's who they are that's the
whole point right it's a
massive part of their carefully created
existence right
so indeed just because it might um seem
a bit obnoxious it might be
counter-productive
it might not be effective it doesn't
mean they're going to stop doing it
because it's who
it is it's a part of who they are rather
than trying to win elections
i've noticed with these hobbyists left
and please feel free to correct me if
it's just me with my chip on my shoulder
but these people do seem to be
contemptuous of
white working class people is that a
fair assumption to make or
am i being unnecessarily harsh come on
mate that's unfair we all are
well so i think there's a couple of
things there right i mean firstly there
are plenty of white working-class people
who are rarely left-wing right you know
i mean but you know they do exist right
so plenty of working class people
are really radical on say i don't know
race gender sexuality whatever
so firstly those people exist secondly
i think absolutely some of these people
are yeah some of these people are openly
contemptuous and hatred of white working
past people as we saw with the uh you
know in bristol
um with the thing that was put up in um
after the coulson statue was taken down
right
this big fat guy in a vest in a bin
clearly reeks of sort of class hatred
and a particular kind of class hatred as
well so those people do exist
but also there are people who
steadfastly
refuse to acknowledge that um you know
there is a correlation between class and
education
and certain political views and in fact
the broader culture there are plenty of
people who say
how dare you imply that lots of white
working-class men
you know it's a skeptical immigration
actually you know
i grew up in the arsenal it becomes like
that monty python like um free auction
schedule for however many options
you know i grew up in the ascend of
nowhere you know and
my dad told me about album which he
loved immigrants and how much he hated
uh capital punishment and for pedophiles
should be go to you know special
education centers nothing so you have
this almost like um
dutch auction of you know i came from
nowhere i'm dead working class me
and yet my whole family loving me so you
also have that section as well
and i think they're the real problem
actually they are the real problem
because
they can't seem to admit that just
because some people who have impeccable
work in class credentials
are indeed very radical on all these
issues as i say and just because their
family
may have been like that doesn't mean
that that's what most people are like
and despite cons you know several uh i
mean
not just opinion polls uh and you know
the best-selling newspapers and all the
rest of it were constant
election results seeming to tell them no
this is not how it is actually
they can't seem to just accept or
concede okay
sure you know some people with
impeccable working-class roots are very
politically radical
most aren't on these issues fine we'll
find a way around that to win elections
anyway
and implement our stuff anyway they just
refuse to concede
david and i want to ask before we move
on to maybe talking about
what a positive vision of the left might
look like uh
just in terms of where are you coming at
it from where are you politically
yeah i mean i'm you know uh probably
unlike most of the people you have on
the show
i'm pretty consistently left-wing on all
sorts of issues actually yeah i'm not
happy with the smear at all mate
we get lots of left-wingers on the show
uh just not work people and the only
reason
for that is is that they won't come on
the show because they don't like
debating their ideas
uh but yeah anyway carry on yeah that's
fair enough that's what
i mean it depends what you mean by woke
right but for me i would say woke is
it's like hobbyist idea right yeah the
identity itself rather than actual
policies that you believe
so yeah i'm pretty left-wing across the
board obviously on economics but also on
you know i don't know race immigration
gender lgbt all this stuff
but i recognize that this is because of
my
privilege to use a word that you might
not like you know i recognize that
you know look at all the [ __ ] books
behind me i recognize this is because i
went to a certain university and i have
a phd
and i have this fancy pants life in
london and all the rest of it okay sure
i haven't got a full-time job
but you know i'm doing pretty well for
myself and i'm never going to be you
know
so many of these issues um which might
cause people to be more skeptical on
these issues
for example you know many feminists who
genuinely
uh are worried about um you know not
trans women but
men basically men pretending to be trans
women to get access to their
changing rooms or something like that
you know plenty of these women have
these beliefs uh you know completely
genuinely and they're not
bigots they're not transphobes they
honestly have these beliefs right
now that's not something that's ever
going to affect me right it will
literally never affect me as a man
likewise i don't you know what happens
with israel and palestine
literally my wife's israeli actually so
it doesn't awake but you know me
personally
you know it has no effect on me right
again you know i probably could live and
work
anywhere in the world frankly so i don't
care about immigration you know i'm
going to be the immigrant right
so this is the thing even though i'm
very left-wing on all these issues
i at least have the sort of
self-awareness to recognize
why i'm so consistent left within all
these issues it's because i don't have
to worry about them
it's because i've got a really good
education it's because i have a you know
fairly fancy pants lifestyle in london
and i think this this is the thing so
many people who are like me politically
don't seem to have this sort of
self-awareness to realize you know
this is why i have these opinions
because it's perfectly safe for me to
have them
i have no skin in the game as it were
that's a really curious thing though
because i'm i'm just interested in terms
of your own psychology just on
to get my head around it so you say you
recognize that
your opinions are based on having the
privilege of not having to
essentially to deal with the
consequences right
is that fair or is that unfair it seems
nothing to do with the consequences
because i don't know what the
consequences would be
right so well i mean you say you're left
wing on that let's just take the trans
issue for example right
so you you're you are
on the kind of new left of that issue is
that
yeah it's it's difficult right i mean
definitely i'm um you know i think
you know fair play trans women are women
trans men and men etc
where i stand on self id is a bit
difficult because
that's that's a you know if someone can
literally say without having had you
know any hormone treatment any
operations
without having had you know anything
from a from a doctor or anything to say
yes i am a man or i am a woman that's
very difficult for me to endorse that
but again
as a man as a cis man it's never going
to affect me you know what i mean
it's so it's almost like i don't i don't
have a dog in that fight i don't have
skin in the game
so on the one hand it's it's difficult
for me to to have a
concrete opinion on it um because i do
all right
i i don't want to delve into the
specifics of that issue i'm not trying
to pin you to the wall anything i'm just
trying to understand so let's take the
immigration issue for example
because of who you are and how you live
uh the impact of immigration is likely
to be positive on your life or have no
effect at all
right that i think that would be fair to
say but but equally you recognize that
there are lots of people for whom that
isn't true
yeah right so does that not affect your
position on immigration because
i suppose the truth is that it's also
true for me
like i more immigration into britain
doesn't make my life particularly worse
and maybe in some ways it benefits
my life right but but i am quite firm
on immigration personally because i
recognize the impact and has on the
country as a whole
and i recognize that there are some
people whose lives are very very badly
affected by
uncontrolled mass immigration uh
communities are destroyed
there's a lot of displacement uh people
feel like
uh society changes faster than they can
cope with
it's something that they feel they've
had no input in etc right so
while my position is that i personally
am not affected
or if i'm affected positively i can see
that the consequences which is why i
take the overall view that
we need to control immigration quite
carefully um
so so what's the difference between you
and i'm just genuinely curious trying to
understand
well see the thing is that in terms of
the immigration question
uh you know the numbers are behind the
more immigration skeptical route right i
mean
you know obviously you saw with the
brexit referendum
okay certain disingenuous brexiteers
like daniel hannon or whatever so you
know
we're not anti-immigration we're just
going to replace europeans or like
indians and people like that and think
yeah well let's see what happens if so
many brexit voters if that happens right
you know the numbers are there with with
the immigration i mean we've had you
know 10 years of conservative
governments
uh almost you know six years or so far
the last four of those years have been
someone who's become prime minister
because they're riding this sort of you
know brexity anti-immigration wave so
that's an issue where i don't think
people need my help or my defense right
you know the numbers are there with the
sort of anti-immigration camp
so yeah there are absolutely plenty of
people who
feel uh either through economic reasons
or cultural reasons or whatever
that immigration is uh is difficult for
life and has consequences for their life
unfortunately for them they've got you
know a conservative government that is
you know willing to listen to them
uh to a certain degree anyway right they
have numerical
clout right they have democratic clout
um the people who don't have any
democratic clout are the people who are
saying like let's abolish borders let's
just have no voters
the problem is these are souls who say
let's have no borders
whilst they have so little clout and
don't really represent
anyone they they do sort of have a lot
of clout specifically on the left right
you know and they do create this image
on the left for the ordinary person oh
that's what the left's about
right so you know i think on so many
issues
sort of small c conservative issues
that's where the vast majority of the
population are
not least by the way plenty of you know
black and asian britons
uh who are very you know small c
conservative on so many issues
so i don't really think that those
people need my help if you like you know
i think
there's a perfectly good conservative
party for that and you know there's also
like the possibility of a
new brexit party style um startup so i
don't think they need my help
so just to go back to your early
question i think there's there's two
different things which might explain
maybe like the slight disconnect between
you know how i actually feel what i
might advocate right so on the
one-handed consequences yet it is
because
because i don't have skin in the game on
certain issues
i can afford to have a more abstract
theoretical
you know university seminar room view on
these things
but it's not just that i think it's also
because you know i also
feel this way in many ways on things
where there are no consequences one way
or the other like
patriotism for example right now you
know you remember years ago uh with
emily thornbury and she tweeted that
picture from
from rochester i mean horrific thing and
also such a stupid thing for any
politician to do right does he not think
there might be consequences to this and
then poor old ed miliband got asked you
know
what do you think when you see the
england flag and you have to go
cry come on you would you would never be
seen dead
draping an england flag from your house
or your van you know it does not make
you feel pride
and that's fine do you reckon ed miller
has got a fan exactly you know
i don't think he's ever been here about
it i'd love to see him just driving
around yeah
with his copy of the sun there's bacon
connie a bacon sandwich mate let alone
drive a van
exactly yeah exactly so this is it you
know what i mean so there's no way at
miliband but that would be seen dead um
you know
and you know fair play right that's
completely fine he doesn't have to
really he's label either
so but on that issue again you know me i
mean i'm from liverpool and lots of
people from liverpool have real
difficulties with with
english nationalism and english
patriotism as well uh and that's
something that doesn't really
necessarily have any consequences but i
only realized that i
have these opinions the way i would
never have an england flag from my house
is because well firstly i'm from
liverpool and that's a thing as well
but also yeah because of my education
because of my you know my sort of
position and stuff like that
right so it's not necessarily just on
issues where there might
be consequences for other people and not
for me but
you know it's also things where i am
maybe demographically different
from your average britain and therefore
i recognize that i will have views that
are different from your average britain
but i appreciate that and i can come to
terms with it and i think a huge problem
is that so many people on the left
like me with my sort of uh you know uh
background in terms of education and
position right now
just refuse to admit this like refuse
refuse to consider that they are not
representative of the average person
and doesn't the 2019 election
give them any kind of message you'd
think that wouldn't yet you would really
think that you know but this is it
there's no if you look back at just
history right
because even things that went on the
very very i mean labor before tony blair
had only ever won
two working majorities right 1945
and 1966 it wanted a few of our
elections in addition to them but with
very slender
majorities of like under 10 or around 12
something like that
so if you look at history laban hardly
ever ever ever ever ever wins
when labor has won like in 45 and 66 and
tony blair's time
it's done it's been very careful it's
worked really hard to deal with these
negative images that people have of
left-wing politics
it's been very sophisticated in its
messaging it's rode you know the second
world war like in 1945 and it's used up
to its advantage
and none of that has ever made certain
people on the left think
um maybe our ideas aren't popular so
i was really thinking that one good
thing that might have come about
out of the 2019 election is that maybe
for some people on the left
they would wake up to the fact that okay
sure some of our economic ideas are
popular great but all the other stuff
really isn't
and actually if you want to implement
some of this other stuff we just need to
be a bit quieter about it and be a bit
less obnoxious
but not you know not a bit of it right
they didn't even draw breath no sooner
had
the so-called red wall fallen instead of
actually
this leading certain people on the left
to think you know what maybe the
northern working class
aren't the sort of you know hipsters in
hackney that we imagine him to be
no sooner had that happened you have the
likes of navarro saying
these people aren't the real working
class you know the real working class
m.a students in uh in brighton and
hackney and you know
so this is the problem right you know
they didn't even miss a beat
i've i think i mean i didn't watch it
but i believe after the exit poll came
out on election night
the likes of ashar khan and ambassador
were having this uh
you know podcast or whatever or
something like that where they were you
know
talking about what's going next and
again they didn't have this sort of
period of [ __ ] you know maybe
everything believe is bollocks you know
they didn't have this period of you know
quiet contemplation
they were straight on the uh talking
nonsense and again
you know the the um the argument has
been that
actually these people uh who you know
voted tory aren't really working class
you know
the real working class are the people
who already vote later so i don't think
there will ever be
a sort of empirical uh way of
of causing these people to ever think oh
no maybe we should just try another
attack
and don't i mean let's cut to the chase
here right we've been talking about you
know this this
fraction of the left the fact that
labour haven't won
for 10 years even though you look at the
government under theresa may who were
pretty much useless one of the most
hated prime ministers there's ever been
is a labour party fit for purpose
because i don't think it is anymore from
being brutally honest
i mean it's it's really difficult to say
isn't it um i think
definitely no matter who beca and this
is what so many people have been saying
uh you know auntie stone the people in
the labour party oh why isn't star wars
it wasn't labour doing better
it's it's always been really difficult
for labor to to win elections in this
country and get into power always like
for 120 years of its history
um it's it's much more difficult now
given what's happened in scotland
uh et cetera given what's happened in
england actually over the past 15 years
with the labour vote
um it depends what you mean to be fifth
or purpose right so if we consider its
first purpose to be clause one of the
labour constitution which is
to get into power right to apply
political power in parliament
it's trying to be understand you know
they are trying now to go back down that
route of actually
giving a damn about where most people
are and what actually might win
elections
whereas yeah clearly for the previous um
sort of uh four years it didn't seem to
give much of a damn about that
but yeah it it it's going to really
struggle and but just because it's going
to really struggle
this doesn't necessarily mean that it's
not fit for purpose
i completely take the point that many of
i mean when we consider what the labour
party was founded to do and what it was
meant to represent
in many ways it doesn't necessarily
represent that but of course you know
demographics have changed people have
changed right so i read a brilliant book
recently by claire ainsley called
the new working class i believe claire
ainsley is a i think ivh
uh kia starm's chief of staff or someone
pretty high up in his operation
and she makes the point that you know
the working class very much still exists
uh it looks slightly different to what
it was 70 years ago
but interest and you might hear some
like you know corbin easter's going yeah
you tell them claire
well actually the point is they care
about the same things that the
traditional working class cared about
you know they care about
family they care about their community
they care about
patriotism and their country right
whether they be white brown black
whatever
they care about these issues um so yeah
that the labour party can still have a
role to play and i think definitely on
the kia stammers coming back to that
role
whether it can win elections or whatever
yeah that's that's definitely a
difficult thing to say i've got no idea
they can
because right now it doesn't look as
though that's going to happen anytime
soon but
isn't that fundamentally dangerous for
democracy
that we effectively have a one-party
state where it's
the conservatives winning time and time
and time again and it doesn't matter how
crap and useless they are
like boris johnson we can all accept now
is crap
he doesn't have the ideas he's
absolutely bungled the last few months
but it doesn't matter
because stamina isn't going to win so
what's the point
sorry i'm getting angry no it's a fair
enough this is a
you know infuriating situation
especially given all the stuff you've
just been talking about right
the tories record in government over the
past 10 years they're they're handing or
bundling bungling sorry bungling rather
than
of this pandemic yeah it's infuriating
both in terms of what they've done what
they've been able to get away with and
the way it looks as though there's no
end in sight
and absolutely i think that is a problem
for democracy but it's not necessarily a
problem of the labour party's
uh creation at least not the current
labor party right so it's other things
it's things like the fixed term
parliament act right which says there's
not going to be an election for you know
another four years
it's things like face past the post
which means that actually
which means sorry that you know it it's
not really even about
uh the numbers that you get necessarily
it's about where the voters are right
um it's about things like uh the media
again you know the fact that so much of
the of the print media
is ridiculously hostile to any labor
leader even if they're quite anodyne one
like tony blair or even poor old
miliband you know so yeah i think
there's there's a huge problem here
again and if you look at so much of the
uh media and i include sky news and to a
certain extent the bbc as well
when you look at um their coverage of
boris johnson and his handling of the
pandemic
i think there you can say they need to
get the tongue out of his arse really
they need to be more critical
especially as you say when the tories
have been in power for 10 years and it
doesn't look as though there's any
serious threat of the opposition taken
over
maybe the media could do better to um
you know to criticize the tories so yeah
i completely take the point about uh
labour weakness being a problem with the
democracy in this country
but there's many other problems like
such this voting system
uh you know and the media and so on well
it's interesting
the media thing always comes up whenever
i talk to people on the
left and they always have the perception
i think that
um you know the institutions of the
media are
in hock with the the conservative
establishment whereas i think a lot of
people on the right field the hashtag
defunderbbc
it's gone super woke uh you know it's
been so
diversity obsessed everyone from
minority backgrounds now
actually over represented there you know
i appear on the bbc quite regularly my
experience of it is that it's super work
right um so and i'm not even on the
right and it's interesting
you know i i know what everybody says
mate well
and actually that was the point that i
was just going to make because i i'm
really enjoying this conversation with
you david because
you you made the the suggestion that a
lot of our guests uh
are right off center and i would argue
that
you are precisely the sort of person
that is actually quite common on our
show
i mean you know you probably to the left
of people like andrew doyle in the sense
of your position on trans or whatever
but you're the exactly the sort of
person that says
the left needs to do better uh and then
the the far left goes well this guy is
on the right he's got an israeli wife
case closed he's a nazi right
so so this is i think one of the
problems is that
our definition of what's on the left is
changed a lot you know andrew is a
socialist for example i don't know if
you're familiar with andrew doyle
right but he people say that he's on the
right people say that francis is on the
right
people say that i'm on the right so
there's a lot of
um there's a lot of kind of i think both
sides
are attempted to say the media is on the
other team side
you know anyone who's not with us is
against us
uh do you find that as you make the
critique of the left that you've made
that a lot of people want to just
dismiss you
uh because of your wife's background or
whatever else it might be
i mean yeah it's more that i'm i'm
critiquing the left and
you know i'm contributing from there but
why don't you talk about the right is it
well there's plenty of people doing that
right you know there's no shortage of
talking heads and journalists and
activists and academics
who are going to lay into boris johnson
and trump and great you know i hate
trump i hate johnson but
who cares i mean yeah i don't want to it
amazes me the way so many people simply
want to read
opinions which they already have or see
opinions that they already have
given straight back to them right you
know i already think that johnson and
trump
tosses the question is what can we do
about it like can we actually do
anything about it
why do people vote for them you know how
can we get rid of them
these are the questions that i'm
interested in and this is what you know
what what i'm about but it seems that so
many people on the left
think that if you're asking those
questions rather than just saying for
the hundredth time
trump and john johnson have scum that
yeah you're some you're some kind of
traitor really you know and that's a
problem
but when it comes to the media i suppose
it depends right so
obviously the bbc through the nature of
the sort of people who work at the bbc
right you know from the top down
being you know overwhelmingly university
graduates and fairly elite university
graduates at that
being overwhelmingly white being
overwhelmingly middle class obviously
they're going to have certain opinions
which
on cultural issues are going to skew
left absolutely
but on other issues like i don't know
the economy for example or
you know what should a prime minister
what is prime ministerial you know what
is confidence
then actually on those issues they might
be either pretty centrist or pretty
right wing right
and again definitely social media and
what depends where you look on social
media but certain elements of social
media
are completely dominated by the left but
so what who cares you know it's
completely powerless it doesn't do
anything
so is this and this is a big problem for
left actually in that it seems that in
certain areas
the left or wokeness if you like is
dominant but
really these areas aren't powerful and
it doesn't have much of an effect
it's an interesting point you make about
the bbc because i suppose
given the nature of our show what we
have focused on at the moment
is primarily what you might call the
culture war
so if you look at the bbc through the
prism of the culture war you go well
on the cultural issues the bbc is
massively left-wing
whereas as you point out maybe on
economics that isn't quite as true
so i see i see what you're saying but
look we've got about
10-15 minutes left and i've really
really genuinely enjoyed our
conversation i have to say
francis is nodding as well it's really a
pleasure to talk to someone who's
um you know you are certainly more to
the left than many of our guests i would
say
at least it seems that way which is
great it's fantastic we we love to have
to have these conversations so let's use
the last
10 15 minutes to talk about a positive
vision
of what the left might be because i'll
give you this example
we were sitting around having dinner the
other day uh with for me francis
anton our producer and a few of our of
our friends
and we were talking about paul embry who
we mentioned who is a socialist trade
union member
but pro brexit who we've had on the show
a couple of times
and we were all saying that if he was
the the labor leader
the chances are that all seven of us
around that table would vote
for labor right uh so
how does labor get back to a position
and the left more broadly perhaps get
back to a position
where it can attract the votes of
amazing people like us
yeah well this is the thing i mean i've
got nothing necessarily against paul
embry but i know that lots of people
uh not that many people in the great
scheme of things of course but
certain people would be would not vote
later if paul embry was in charge
sure i mean these people are numerically
very small actually
every single one that's got a twitter
account every single one of them uses it
with a
vengeance but you know nationwide the
small people but they do exist
so i mean an example i always like to
use is the
harold wilson administration of the
1960s right so
from 1964 to 1970 won two elections
and in that period with roy roy jenkins
as the home secretary
they abolished the death penalty they
legalized abortion they relaxed
the divorce rules they stopped flogging
in prisons which used to be a thing
of the 60s you've lost conscience you've
lost me mate that's where all went wrong
bring back the birch exactly you know
they they
the uh they decriminalized homosexuality
they did all of these
they also passed race relations
legislation as well they did all of
these great
liberal you know culturally left-wing
non-economic things
uh but of course none of this was in the
manifesto apart from the race relations
thing
once you know they didn't they didn't
you know they weren't idiots right they
didn't actually say knowing full well
what their voters were like as well
they didn't say oh we're going to say in
our 64 or 66 manifesto
yeah we're going to legalize being gay
we're going to legalize abortion we're
going to
abolish the death penalty they didn't
say that at all it wasn't even official
government policy right they just gave
time for most of it anyway
they gave time to uh private members
bills they allowed backbenchers to
sponsor this legislation the government
gave it time
and and they got it through and i think
that's a fine example
of the sort of savviness if you like of
what the left needs to do the left needs
to realize that
you know aside from the the state of the
people who've been in power for the past
10 years
aside from all sorts of existential
challenges in terms of the economy in
terms of climate change
stuff like that aside from all of the
great stuff that the left wants to do on
on various kinds of issues economic and
non-economic
if it wants to actually do that and put
this stuff into practice
it's really tough right it's really
tough to win elections it's really tough
to get into power
so it needs to just have no uh sort of
false assumptions it needs to have no
illusions about what the electorate is
like
uh and what they need to do to get them
david hold on i'm sorry to interrupt but
if i just put my like if i pretend to be
on the right for
for the purposes of this question right
then what i'm hearing
and this is i appreciate putting an
uncharitable spin on what you've said
but
but this is what people will hear no
doubt is
we need to lie to the lecturer and trick
them into accepting policies that they
don't like
so i would say not at all right so it's
not as though you need to
lie in that you literally say in the
manifesto we're going to do x y and z
and then do the opposite or okay put in
the manifesto we're going to do x y and
z
and then do it right although obviously
politicians
could be accused of doing stuff like
that quite often it's more a case of
don't focus on unpopular [ __ ] right so
for example
israel palestine is not an issue that
most people care about one way or the
other
but if you obsess over israel palestine
then you will attract loads of
anti-semites to your cause of course
and you know you will look as though
maybe you're not an anti-semite but
maybe as though you are unduly concerned
with this very very very small part of
the world that doesn't appear to have
much to do with the uk
likewise considering how few trans
people are in the population
if you're always banging on about trans
rights that people don't really care one
way or the other right
so you could move i mean you know the
tories nearly introduced self id
i think in in theresa may's government
and stuff like that so
it's the sort of thing whereby these are
these aren't necessarily
issues that elicit passions rarely
necessarily amongst the general
population they haven't discussions
amongst a very small group of people on
both sides
but it's not really the sort of thing
that people care about if you had a
labor government
which was doing important things on the
economy on the nhs on education
on housing for god's sake you know if
you could if you had a labor government
which was achieving results in all of
these spheres
very very very few people would give a
damn
if you also try to advance some of the
more niche concerns of you know
eccentrics on university campuses and on
twitter
and it wouldn't really be about lying to
the electorate
the same way that the wilson governments
didn't lie to the electorate you know
they had cross-party consensus for what
they were doing
and i know i'm slightly contradicting
what i said earlier about you know how
uh for 50 or 60 years after the death
penalty was abolished
there was actually majoritarian support
in favor of the death penalty but
not enough people actually cared about
this right yeah not
enough people actually cared about this
issue to
to make the tories for example shift to
the right yeah like if you ask them
they'll say they're in favor of the
death penalty but they're not going to
go on a march to to
execute people yeah yeah that makes
sense
that makes sense so basically what
you're saying is if the left focused on
big issues that most people care about
if they
if they had economic policies that were
front and center of their agenda
and they were not sidelined by marginal
issues which
seem crazy to most people you know if so
if they delivered them that
they could afford them to slip in a few
little things like you know being tough
on jews and tough on the causes of jews
or whatever else it might be
they could afford on say to re-evaluate
britain's foreign policy priorities
right so in terms of you know our
relationship with america which has not
been very good for
britain or for you know iraq or
afghanistan and stuff like this
yeah and things like that for example
right
things that lots of people will support
i mean sorry to you know go off in a
little tangent here but
one of the things about corbyn which you
know makes me think this is
he's emblematic of this hobbyist left
tendency is you know
how hard would it have been for him to
sing along gusterly at the cenotaph you
know
and how hard would it have been for him
uh in the aftermath of the
street poisonings to say yeah russia
scumbags
to just go through with this almost
performative
yet you know being a politician going
along with the going get and then
actually
if you got into power then you could
defund the monarchy say or whatever you
know or you could try to sort of um
have anti-monarchical policies that you
could get away with then you could
actually
you wanted to uh you know reorientate
britain's foreign policy
uh you know away from maybe a sort of
instinctively sort of anti-russian
pro-american stance but this is it he
just couldn't even
he wouldn't even do that you know he
wouldn't even go through the motions of
singing and
save the queen uh you know and just
being sort of oh yeah the russians
declared behind his poisoning so
this is the thing i'm not saying that
this would actually win labor elections
but at least we'd have a fighting chance
if we you know could do these things and
definitely i think you know this country
needs
a labor government i would say so uh but
you know even francis would say whether
it needs a labor government or not
it definitely needs opposition right it
definitely needs to be incredible
uh you know opposition and but and dave
you say all these things and you're
talking i mean look we've been talking
about the left
for what 55 minutes the first time we've
even mentioned the housing crisis
to me that is absolutely absolutely yeah
this is it's ridiculous
and this is the thing that you know
compared to say sort of political
debates programs of like 40 50 years ago
right if you look on youtube of debates
in the 70s
it's all about like trade union rights
it's all about taxation
it's all about these sorts of issues and
okay yeah sure they talk about foreign
policy and
sort of cultural stuff as well but it's
about the great economic issues of the
day
and this is the thing you know it's
almost as though
on the one hand there's there's
obviously far more consensus now on
economic issues
uh than there used to be decades ago and
this included when corbyn
was labor leader by the way there was
still more um consensus on economic
issues than happened in the past
uh but also it's because of the sort of
people who are on the left now you know
the sort of people
who are really at the sharp end of the
housing crisis say and i don't mean
people like me who have to pay through
the nose for flats that they can't
really afford
i mean people on the streets i mean
families who are forced to stay in dnbs
right
i mean those sorts of people they're not
on the left you know they're not uh
going to clp meetings they're not going
on marches
they're not you know on social media
making [ __ ] of themselves so this is
the thing right
it's not only that there seems to be
economic issues seem to have faded to
obeys to a certain extent that there's
much more of a consensus than there used
to be
but there's also that the sort of people
on the left has completely shifted
it's not the people who really need
economic change now who are the loudest
voices and the most prominent people on
the left
it's people who are actually doing
pretty alright actually
i mean you you talk about these things
and like i said we talk about housing
the first time we've talked about it in
an hour's interview which again is
ridiculous and you talk about
this need for the left to embrace these
ideas
take on these challenges fundamentally
change
its outlook and i'm sitting here and i'm
going you know what that sounds great
but it ain't gonna [ __ ] happen
why is that well this is it and
like you cynical bastard that's why
believe
believe anything is possible for answers
if you look at what as you said before
like you know the the december 2019
general election you'd think that for
certain people this would be a wake-up
call
but not a bit of it right but i think
under kirsten
and not just i mean you know not just
him but some of the people behind them
as well like claire ainsley
who i mentioned earlier a lot of these
people are
very sensible by sensible i mean people
like
they they care about winning elections
and they're concerned with that they're
concerned with what is possible with
what they can
what they should present to the public
so i honestly do think that the stamina
regime
whilst it uh quite sensibly makes all
kinds of
gestures one way or the other so for
example starman angela rainer both
took a knee for black lives matter and
again horrific photo op i thought
really pathetic but again this is the
sort of um
left-wing performativity that can be
good actually right
because starmah doing that then gives
him breathing space to say
i didn't approve of uh whilst the
coulson statue should have come down
i didn't approve of the manner in which
it happened which of course is where
most people are by the way so
this is i think stamina is showing
really good promise you know he knows
what to do in terms of symbolism and in
terms of um
performativity to keep certain groups
happy but he's also got his eyes firmly
on the prize
and hopefully knows what it takes to win
elections
well he's certainly better better than
his predecessor you can definitely say
that
and look the thing the thing that i get
from our conversation is that actually
there's so many issues i mean francis
brings up the housing crisis him and i
talk about
every time we meet in london we look
around us and we go
there's something seriously wrong with
this country
because the streets are full of people
we went we were in trafalgar square a
couple of weeks ago
and they're accused of hundreds of
people
just standing there to get food
in trafalgar square in the center in of
our capital one of the biggest and most
wealthy cities in the world
um there are people in there they're
basically tents springing up all over
all over the streets of london for
homeless people there's a problem and i
i don't believe that the majority of the
people
of this country are content with that i
think that there's
there's an overwhelming majority of
people in this country who don't want
that to be the case and who would want
those people to be helped and who would
want them to be looked after
whether it's mental health support
whether it's housing whatever it might
be
uh i think there is a consensus for all
those things but the problem is
that you know the left has to get a [ __ ]
together which is
one of the reasons that you've been
criticizing them i imagine and this is
one of the reasons that we've been
talking to people who are critical
because we want them to do better
that's not to say that i am this i'm in
the center i'm kind of i've voted for
pretty much every party
within the mainstream uh throughout my
life i used to write lib damn for god's
sake right
um you're pulling a face of me you've
got labor mate
but no i actually i voted for corbyn at
some point you know so
my point is i suspect most of the
country is about where i am which is
bang in the center and
if people in the labor party were to get
their [ __ ] together they might find that
even with the loss of scotland which is
a problem of course
they could win the country back over if
they just stop focusing on all this
stupid stuff
that that's very divisive and and
frankly where the country is absolutely
not with them
yeah fair enough i mean this is this is
absolutely the message of my book and
you know
someone said to me one so why don't you
write a book about the rights you think
well the right's doing pretty well for
itself frankly you know i mean the right
doesn't need any
uh you know uh critique or hell
criticism or help now
it's been doing pretty well for the past
10 years at least so yeah
i completely agree with that you know
the thing the fl i mean i you know i
remember
that those of us who were alive you know
15 20 years ago we can literally
remember having seen with our own eyes
the streets did not look like that the
way they do now in liverpool and
manchester united
the proliferation of homeless people
that this the existence of food banks
you know
didn't really exist at all ten years ago
as far as i'm aware you know people can
see the evidence of this with their own
eyes
um and and this is again a problem i
think in that
you know the left used to be about
common sense right the left used to be
saying it is not right
that some people are extremely rich and
other people go hungry and i
have no home it is not right that you
know white people have to these things
but some people don't because the
color of their skin that was really sent
simple and and sort of feed it off
people's common sense
now lots of people on the on the left
say ah well common sense is a social
construct you know haven't you read
gramsci and
yeah common senses of social constructs
but what what what relevance does that
have to politics right it doesn't you
know
that that isn't an academic seminar room
observation to say that common sense is
a social construct you know
we need to okay say fine we can agree
with that
what how is that going to affect our
election strategy right so
this is it absolutely people are fed up
and angry and
and i think also this whole a level
fiasco is another nail
maybe not in the tories coffin but
definitely in the johnson
government's coffin i mean this is going
to be a big problem for them further
down the line i think
in the same way that the the coronavirus
death toll
and possible uh depression might be so
there's definitely an appetite for
change absolutely 100
and i honestly think that whilst you
know labor has all sorts of
uh disadvantages that election time if
the last labor um you know
election campaign was led by somebody
who didn't have all of corbyn's baggage
and didn't have all of this sort of you
know voter repellent
ideology on so many issues you know the
poll done immediately afterwards for
people who didn't vote labor why didn't
you vote labour right number one by
countrymen
corbyn the leader number two brexit and
then only number three
there's ever no policies on a manifesto
or something like that right so
i think people are desperate for change
uh
but so many of the people who are most
desperate for change up and down the
country
as we saw in these red wall seats it's
not as though these red wall seats voted
tory
because they've had this spurge of
affluence uh over the past ten years now
they're becoming all middle class
not at all right if anything it's quite
the opposite so people are desperate for
change and people
would vote for a party which seems to be
offering this kind of change
if it could just package it in a voter
family package
that's a really really really uh salient
and brilliant point and unfortunately
it's not gonna [ __ ] happen but there
we go
anyway uh you've been absolutely
brilliant dave thank you so much for
coming on the show and thank you for
being
uh coming on and talking about the left
and being a left-wing guest and
uh trying to uh cleanse our reputation
for being alright nazis and all the rest
of it
so thank you very much for that well
that's not gonna happen he's just gonna
become one of us now that's all
absolutely mate so yeah uh yeah well
you're already halfway there
you're marrying an israeli lady so yeah
you've got one foot in the door
uh but dave we always end our shows with
uh the same question which is uh what is
a one thing we're not talking about as a
society
that we really should be yeah oh as a
society so yeah so as a society that's
interesting because
i don't know about as a society i think
something in politics really
is that a lot of people say black people
asian people
gay people women are often really right
wing right
and i think this is going to be the
issue in politics over the next hundred
years
the way the last election almost
completed the
uh tories making massive inroads into
into the traditional working class
i think the big political thing of the
next century will be the tories winning
over
loads of asian votes loads of black
votes they're already
doing it with british indians i think
they're going to be doing it with them
you know i mean
so many uh say british people from an
african background
are like norman tevit or margaret
thatcher's ideal people
like they are proper you know pull
yourself up by your bootstraps
uh you know it's all about hard graft
and personal responsibility
these people are really right wing in
many ways and if the tory party can just
shake
its well-deserved reputation for racism
a lot of these people are going to be
going over to the tories in the next few
decades
so not really a social thing necessarily
more of a political thing but i think
this is one thing that nobody's talking
about you know the left always goes on
about you know
um these groups of like women gays
disabled people god knows why they think
disabled people are so left-wing you
know by the way you know but whatever
so i think this is the thing that we're
going to see over the next few decades
lots of people from these
these groups that the left is trying to
put into this rainbow coalition are
going to become more and more right-wing
fascinating stuff david listen i have to
say we genuinely
really really enjoyed the conversation
we'd love to get you back at some point
as well to chat more about this sort of
stuff
thank you so much for coming on the book
is absolutely fantastic
i recommend that everybody gets it a
left for itself
uh and uh where should people follow
your ramblings online if
if there's such an opportunity i'm on
twitter at
davidswift87 perfect
thank you so much nice one although i've
got to be honest with you whenever i
talk about the left i get
i get just really angry anyway it's fine
mate you just haven't eaten for about 45
minutes that's all that's happened
we'll get a burger yeah
yeah anyway
i can't i can't talk and they just get
me so angry
anyway i'm gonna shut up we're gonna
let's end the episode so i can go and
kick something
all right fantastic stuff guys thank you
so much for watching
make sure you get the book it's
absolutely brilliant
a left for itself and we'll see you very
soon with another live stream
or another interview 7 p.m uk time every
day
except mondays we've got something for
everybody see you very soon
take care guys see you soon
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
triggerpod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word